- Today on Drew, take a deep
dive into the season one.
- I'm so in awe that
we're all still so close,
we've experienced everything together.
- [Announcer] And we gear
up for our star study,
two weeks premier event.
- In my original hometown of Hollywood.
I grew up here in Los
Angeles, I love it here.
It all starts now.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Please
welcome Drew Barrymore.
- Hi everyone, the countdown
is for season two premiere.
of the Drew Barry Marchelle.
It's less than a week away.
And the first thing we're
gonna do is show our undying
appreciation for all of our hometowns.
I'm gonna start in my
hometown of Los Angeles.
But before we do that,
let's take a look back at how we got here.
These are our favorite
moments from season one,
and we curated them just for you.
We kicked off the season
premiere with two women that
I just, well, they're
my nearest and dearest.
That first guest is a
really important thing
in the talk show world,
and I actually said,
could I have my friends on?
You might happen to know
who they are, ironically,
it's Cameron Diaz and Lucy Lu,
my fellow Charlie's Angels.
Take a look.
We all made Charlie's Angels.
We made it and we're making this show.
And so when we sat around
and thought about who is this
you know, first guest?
Nothing felt right, nothing was there.
And all of the sudden in
like a divine intervention,
I was like Cameron and Lucy,
and everything fell into place.
- Massive, congratulations,
this is really major for you.
(audience applauding)
- Listen, you know, everybody says,
who's gonna be your first guest.
It's like, I mean, we've been
through everything together.
- Well, everything.
- Everything.
- Literally everything.
- I haven't had a wedding
that you guys haven't been at.
- I've been to all your weddings,
I've been to all of them.
- Like when our babies are born,
we hang out and we do
the birthday party thing.
I can't believe we're all moms now.
That's when I got really emotional.
First, I sent Cameron
a video and I'm saying,
Hey, listen, I got it like,
I wanna ask you something
when you come on the show,
which, I mean, I've never
done this in my life
because I'm so comfortable.
I mean, we have lived
together all over the world.
So of course, to save time,
I sent her a video while
I'm getting dressed
and you don't see anything,
I'm not that dumb,
but I'm getting out of the shower
and I'm like wringing out of my towel.
And I don't hear back from
her for like two days.
And I'm like, this is weird.
What is going on?
So I text her and I'm like, I
don't care about the question.
Are you okay?
I don't hear again for two
days and I'm freaking out.
So I call her and I'm
like, what is going on?
I'm worried, is everything okay?
She's like, I don't know
what you're talking about.
I'm like the video.
You didn't get my video?
Turns out a young boy
got the video.
(laughs)
- Lucky him. Oh no.
- Oh, no.
- Oh, no, by the way, it's
like seven minutes long.
- Oh, my God.
(laughs)
- It's like epic.
I mean, this is some material-
- Secret revealed.
- Material for like,
honestly, this is gonna last
him three or four years.
(laughs)
- I mean, I'm really like hamming it up
because it's, you know-
- 'Cause it's you.
- I was like, send me
that video immediately.
I need to know what is in that video.
And the whole while I'm just
like cracking up because-
- You need to send me this video as well,
or do it through someone
else because I didn't get
your other video either.
- So then I said...
No, something's wrong with my phone.
So I sent Lucy this video crying,
inviting her on the show saying-
- In her bathroom crying.
- I'm in my bathroom.
- She was dressed.
- I was fully clothed at this time.
I didn't take the risk and she
didn't get the video either.
- Come on.
- I know, I know.
The thing that I love about
our friendship is that
we have been there in all the
big and important moments.
We've also been there in the small moments
and the casual moments.
And the reason we are such good friends
is because it's real.
And we go through real
stuff with each other.
It's not a Hollywood fairytale.
- There's no aspect of life
that's an actual Hollywood fairytale.
That's why it's a Hollywood fairytale
'cause it doesn't exist.
It's aspirational, it's hopeful,
but life is constantly
full of twists and turns
and all those things that
happen over a lifetime,
because truly it is now a lifetime.
I mean, 20 years is a long time y'all.
Like, I'm two years away from 50.
You know, that's nearly half my life.
We have Charlie's Angels
as our sort of backdrop
that brought us together.
But then we get to fill
in all of life together
and real moments, which I
just so appreciate, so much.
- It's so true.
- It's so well said to me.
- I know.
- Because it's like, it's
our touch point, you know?
But then we have that foundation
and then we've obviously
grown and learned and changed.
And I mean, I know that
20 years has gone by,
but I feel like it was yesterday.
I feel just as fresh and
as young and as you know,
creatively, I don't know,
excited as I was when I started.
- Here's the thing about Charlie's Angels,
is that it's about girls who
can do all of these things
and love each other.
And don't have competition and
support each other and laugh
and wanna talk about love
and life so much that they
actually start to talk about loving life
while they're fighting,
because women are so like
that at all intersect.
And that is why I asked
you guys here today,
is because if you're
gonna do something big,
you wanna do it with your girlfriends.
- That's right.
(audience applauding)
And I love being together.
Although are we really together?
Are we all together in this room?
- Are we?
I feel like we're connected
in some way, but maybe.
- For anyone watching,
can you guess which one
of us isn't really here?
(dramatic music)
(gasping)
Welcome back.
- I'm the one in Los Angeles.
(laughing)
You gotta try this, it's so incredible.
The ether, the little
particles going out into space
and coming back and remapping
into this beautiful space.
You guys, it's crazy, you should try it.
It tingles.
(laughs)
(audience applauding)
- All right, we're not
done yet with those ladies,
more with Cameron and Lucy up next.
(upbeat music)
♪ If you're into fashion ♪
♪ Or easy home decor ♪
♪ New favorite recipes ♪
♪ Plus fun celebrities ♪
♪ With a little good news ♪
We're back to bring you more.
♪ Barrymore, choose a
little for season two ♪
♪ Yeah, Barrymore, life
improving, stain removing ♪
♪ Barrymore ♪
- [Announcer] The new season of Drew,
premiere September 13th.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome back, we just
showed our premiere interview
with my nearest and dearest,
Cameron Diaz and Lucy Lou.
Later in that episode,
the three of us dove
into our ongoing roles,
(sighs) as moms, take a look.
So we grew and we grew
up and now we are moms.
Do you think you're a person
now Lucy, than you were then?
Like, aside from us knowing
each other and our friendship,
just you as a human?
- I think in my twenties,
I felt very Bulletproof
and very I don't wanna
say it was risk-taking
'cause it was beyond that.
It was like, I didn't really
care if I lived or died.
I just didn't and I lost
my father a few years ago
and I didn't really recognize the levels
that we have in our lives.
And like he was a place in my life that
was always sort of kind
of a roof, you know?
And so suddenly you feel like
the roof has been torn off and
then you sort of recognize,
oh, I am now the roof,
and I happen to have a child,
so I guess I'm the roof to that child.
So now I really have to understand that
I have to shelter him and
I have a responsibility.
And it's a very powerful thing.
It's also terrifying, if I think about it
I think my heart was smaller back then,
'cause it was sort of more
inclined to what I wanted to do.
But now it's sort of like,
what do we want to do?
And it feels good because I
feel like a fuller person.
Like life seems a much more, you know,
kind of colorful and wild
because there's so many more
opportunities as a mom
to kind of like discover.
And there's so much
more curiosity with kids
and it's mind blowing and
it's actually more terrifying
in a way, you know,
because you're also responsible
for this little person.
- Highest stake.
- So it's like, oh my
God, I thought I was on
a ride back then, a wild ride.
But actually it's now that
it's even more intense.
- Well, you nailed it because
you're just dealing with
your own mortality.
And all of the sudden when you have a kid,
I don't care if it sounds co-dependent,
my kids are more meaningful
to me than my own life.
- I think there's
something that in our DNA
that gets triggered, you know,
like that just clicks on
when you become a parent.
You have to make sure that they survive.
They go on you, we will die.
I'm sorry to get like morbid,
and this is those times when Drew goes
bear, really you're gonna die?
Do we have to talk about that?
- But your first show
was all about mortality.
- I know, I think I'm
ready to about death.
I think I'm no longer a young idiot
who thinks I am immortal,
which I'm glad to know I'm not,
I wasn't the only one.
I mean, I heard myself around,
I abused this carcass to no end
and I just thought Drew,
I was gonna die young.
So who cares, live now and go for it.
And now, yeah, I mean, 2020 will make you
think about your mortality.
Children will make you think
about where your mortality.
- Yeah, in my twenties it was
just sort of like, here we go.
Yeah, all right.
Yep, jump on that.
Gotcha, oh, is that a wild horse?
Oh, cool, yeah, no, I know
how to hold on for my life.
Let's go.
- There's such a liberation
in that too though.
- Yeah, I'm so glad I did it all.
- When I thought about trying
to accomplish something big
in my life at another point,
you two were the people I did it with.
And so of course, what a natural fit
that you're the two people that came into
my head and my heart when I thought,
how would I like to honor this endeavor?
I see myself with you guys.
- I feel like it's exactly
what the world needs.
They need your light,
they need your joyousness.
They need your perspective.
One of the things that I have
always been in total awe of
in you, is your ability to like
take in all the information,
how quick you are to not just
like what's in front of you,
but like the nuances and the sort of,
the humanity and intellect.
You read more books
than any person I know.
You listen to more music,
you look at more art,
you watch more television and film.
You're actually taking
in all the information
and you're synthesizing it.
And you're bringing it into
this really unique perspective.
That is all about how it like
connects all of us together.
Even if it doesn't feel
like it has anything to do
with one another.
And you bring it to the
world in this joyous,
beautiful, like buoyant
light, that is you.
And it's a gift.
It's like truly a gift
that you give the world.
And you're gonna make the world a happier,
better place by giving us that gift.
- You have a big soul and a
big heart and doing this show,
is really special and wonderful because
you have something to share
and you have gone through
tough times in your life.
You've had issues with your
family, you've had issues with,
you know, like marriages, divorces.
You have something to share.
And I don't know that I can
say that about a lot of things.
I've never been married,
I've never been divorced.
I haven't done a lot of
the things that you have.
So to me, the experience that you have
and that you have to share is exciting.
And I think that you should
feel free to do that because
that's who you are.
You're very open, generous person.
- I asked you guys here so
I could honor you today.
That's what this was about for me.
- Yeah, but you can't honor
us without us honoring you,
this is the symbiotic relationship.
And you have to be able to give and take
and understand that,
a lot of times when I give
like a friend a compliment,
they can't take it.
It's time for us to receive.
(audience applauding)
- In this case to say, I love those women,
well, it's just not enough.
And I'm so in awe of the fact
that we're all still so close
and get to talk about being parents,
we've experienced everything together.
My Cameron, I call her auntie poopoo,
is gonna come for season two.
We're gonna do a whole hour together.
It's gonna be so fun.
Stay tuned to find out when that is,
in the season premiere week.
(upbeat music)
♪ If you're into fashion ♪
♪ Or easy home decor ♪
♪ New favorite recipes ♪
♪ Plus fun celebrities ♪
♪ With a little good news ♪
We're back to bring you more.
♪ Barrymore, choose a
little for season two ♪
♪ Yeah, Barrymore, life
improving, stain removing ♪
♪ Barrymore ♪
- [Announcer] The new season of Drew,
premiere September 13th.
(upbeat music)
- Here's the little weekday motivation
from someone who inspires us.
- Hey, Drew, it's your
friend, Zoe, long time.
When I first discovered that
stance was something that
people got paid to do
and made a career out of,
I became instantly obsessed.
My dad at the time was
working at an emergency clinic
as a doctor and a guy
came in with a concussion
and turned out to be a stunt man.
And my dad speaks volumes
about who my father is,
came home with the phone
number 'cause he knew
that I wanted to be a stunt woman.
And I immediately was like,
what are you talking about?
I can't call that person,
just felt so uncomfortable
and gross, and my dad made
an statement that I just,
it stopped me in my tracks because
it was literally irrefutable.
You could make that phone
call today, or you can not.
And if you don't make the phone call,
you'll wake up tomorrow and
it'll be a normal Wednesday,
and you'll be the same Zoe
you are when you went to sleep
and your life will be the
same life you've got now.
And that's all great.
Or you could make the phone
call and you might wake up
tomorrow, getting emotional.
You might wake up tomorrow, a star woman.
It stopped me in my tracks
in a way that I was like, oh,
well then I just need
to make the phone call
because what's the risk, you know?
And that literally was the
beginning of a career where
I had been a stunt
woman and then an actor.
And since producer, and I'm
now getting into directing,
and it's all because of that sense of,
don't say no to something because of fear.
- Now that was inspiring.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back, as we gear up for season two
of the Drew Barrymore show,
it's in less than a week.
And we're looking back at
some of our favorite moments
from season one, and hands down,
one of my favorite moments
was when we introduced our
cookbook club to the world
and to help me do that,
we had the wonderful chef
and all around incredible
human being, Jose Andreas,
take a look.
What are you teaching me today?
- Eggs with chickpeas and tomato sauce.
Do it in five minutes.
- I mean, that's rebel Latori because
that's such a deterrent
because when they say,
prep time, 20 minutes
cook time, 60 minutes.
It's not realistic for
a lot of people's lives.
- So listen, we have the pan,
we have the oil and you have garlic?
- I have garlic right here.
- Pit the garlic on the pan,
and now talk to your garlic.
Tell, Hey garlic, how are you, boy?
How you doing baby?
- Hey baby, how's it going?
My kid's grandfather, RA,
that's what he always says.
Hey baby.
- The garlic is speaking back you.
And the garlic is telling you,
oh, I'm so happy, I'm
cooking with Drew and Jose.
It's amazing.
- I love garlic the more, the better.
- Okay now, in this moment
we put the chickpeas.
- Roger that.
- This is actually great
to buy a can of chickpeas,
which are delicious.
And usually they have very
good price on the supermarket.
- I was gonna say,
I think they're a very
healthy thing for people.
And you have a vegetable
book and for vegetarians
they are really satisfying,
like protein substitute.
I love that.
- Well, you take a look at the chickpeas.
They're are so happy because
they love to be with the garlic.
People don't know this,
but chickpeas and garlic,
they're very friendly.
You'll have to lift up the temperature,
put higher temperature Drew.
- Oh, Jose, I'm so excited to tell you
that I just did that.
That means we're telepathically
linked now, I'm in.
- So in this moment,
this is very important.
I will add a little bit
more of oil to the pan.
I love olive oil.
- By the way, check
this out olive oil out.
Oh, hang on, beauty shot, there we go.
I love your olive oil.
Thank you so much for sending it to us.
- Let's say you have fresh tomatoes.
You can get a peel fresh
tomato and cut it in cubes.
Or you add canned tomatoes
and also works very well.
Or you'll have any pasta tomato
sauce that is already made.
Everything works.
Just make sure that you do
whatever you have at home
is what you use.
- I think that makes people
less stressed in the kitchen.
Thank you.
- Well, Drew, recipes
should be like life itself.
When you're gonna have
some of the ingredients,
use more home, change
the recipe in your dishes
or in your life, and you'll
always be successful.
That's a very important lesson in cooking.
- And in life.
(audience applauding)
- Jose look, I'm sizzling, baby.
- So now I have a can
of a Spanish pimento.
- Yes.
- What we'd called
paprika, if you have it,
if you don't have
paprika put chili flames,
if you don't put cumin,
if you're don't, put whatever spice
you have in your kitchen,
make the recipe your own.
- Oh, paprika, I love you so.
- And now I'm putting the tomato in.
Because this tomato is already cooked,
it's gonna be easy.
I mean, I cannot believe Drew,
that I'm actually cooking with you.
I mean, when I told my
daughters, they were like,
come on, daddy, don't make fine of us.
I'm cooking with her.
- Jose, how old are your daughters?
- I have three, Carlota, she's 21,
Ines she's 19, and Lucia she's 16.
So listen, this is very important.
Now there's tomato sauce, the chickpeas,
and I am putting inside four or five eggs.
In this moment can put
some salt on the eggs.
And ladies and gentlemen,
you cover the pot, and now
you can open a glass of wine.
You can open yourself a
beer, you can drink a Sherry.
So why I'm doing these one
pot, Drew, because very often,
many recipes then require
three or four or five pots.
You can make everything with one pot.
No, cleaning, this is great.
- I love one pot.
I think it really helps people
feel like they can manage.
So one pot for me is, you
know, a great way to cook.
That keeps me calm.
- These pandemic I've
been cooking in a lot
with my daughters and we did
some cooking on social media.
And quite frankly,
we were doing it because it was fun,
because we were spending so many hours.
We began sharing it with people,
and it was one of the
best memories of my life,
to be cooking with my
three daughters, already.
Man, I remember the first
time I had them in my arms
and I was crying.
It was after they came up into the ward.
And now 21 years later,
I realized through this pandemic,
that there are these three grown up girls.
And to me, cooking with my daughters
has been the happiest moment of my life.
- Look at that, look at that beauty shot.
(audience cheering)
And now I'm gonna try it.
Yup, oh yeah.
Oh God, that's good.
- The great thing about this dish is that
you can make it your own in so many ways.
You can cook it every time.
And every time with a different recipe,
you can put some mozzarella,
you can put some manchego cheese.
- Ooh, topping it with cheese
would like kick it up a whole other level.
You're right.
- And don't be afraid
of trying new things,
always take risk.
They will always pay off.
(audience applauding)
- I loved Jose's garlic tip.
I've actually been using
it and it is foolproof.
And when it comes the kitchen,
I will take anything foolproof.
And when it comes to Jose,
I will follow him wherever he goes.
He actually just got a grant
of a hundred million dollars
for his world central kitchen to keep on
taking care of everyone
the way only he can do.
So for more memorable
moments from season one,
they're coming up next, stay tuned.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back, something I find
very authentic about our show
is we try to cover the spectrum.
We laugh, we talk about pop culture.
We cook, clean and just
like in life, we also cry.
We get mad and we like to
deal with the tough stuff.
Last season, I was honored
to get the opportunity
to sit down with Dylan Farrow.
At the time she was the
subject of the documentary
Allen versus Pharaoh
about the alleged abuse
that she endured as a child.
And she was ready to open
up and talk about her story.
I'm very glad that she did it with me.
Take a look.
I wanna say first out of the gate,
I would like to explain myself,
because this is not about me,
but I wanted to sort of
have this type of candor.
I worked with Woody Allen.
I did a film with him in 1996 called
"Everyone Says I Love You."
And there was no higher
career calling card
than to work with Woody Allen.
And then I had children and it changed me
because I realized that
I was one of the people
who was basically gas lit,
into not looking at
a narrative beyond what I was being told.
And I see what's happening
in the industry now.
- Yeah.
- And that is because of you
making that brave choice.
So thank you for that.
- Thank you, oh my goodness.
Hearing what you just said like, I mean,
I'm trying not to cry right now.
But like, it's just so meaningful
because it's easy for me to say, like,
of course you shouldn't
work with him, you know,
he's a jerk, he's a monster,
but I just find it an incredibly brave
and incredibly generous
that you would say to me,
that my story and what I went through
was important enough to reconsider that.
- Absolutely.
And how hard was it,
for you to engage in this document?
In which I really wanna
make a caveat about
that your family did not produce.
- No, no, they came to us.
- I think that's very important
for people to understand
your family did not
produce this documentary.
- No, we participated.
And apparently everyone
was asked to participate.
- Yeah, no, they went to everyone
and that was important, you know,
even just to me to know
that like that there was
a level of journalistic
integrity at work here.
- So did your family get together and say,
these people are different,
they're taking a tone,
they're using a diligence.
There's a thoroughness
here that feels safer
in order to come out and
make this brave decision.
- I was actually the one
who initially told my mom
and told Ronan, you know,
like, Hey, I sat down
with these people and I really think that
they are on the up and up.
So then when my mom
agreed to be interviewed,
I was really, really shocked.
And when Ronan agreed,
I was even more shocked.
And then Fletcher agreed,
I mean, I was picking my jaw
up off the floor and, you know,
gradually more and more
of my siblings signed on
and a few of them didn't
and I've spoken to them
about that too.
And I respect that decision as well.
But I mean, in terms
of like family meeting,
not really, but there was communication.
And interestingly, the
documentary has led to
greater communication between
us as a result, I think,
which is interesting.
- May I ask why you were
surprised that they signed on?
- I think mostly because
we wouldn't talk about it
to each other.
So talking about it publicly,
it just seemed absolutely
incomprehensible.
- How did your mom feel
watching the documentary?
- I mean, it was tough
because I would have loved
to have been able to
watch the series with her,
and at the time that just wasn't possible.
We were in separate quarantine
pods, unfortunately.
So I really sort of
heard everything from her
after the fact, you know,
it was just a very strange pathway
that we navigated separately and together,
but I think it definitely
changed a lot about
how me and my mom relate to each other
and interact with each other.
And I think there's a very renewed level
of just respect, just woman to woman.
- I mean, sometimes when I think back on
memories of my life, there
has like a gauze, a patina,
a sort of surrealist reverie.
I know mentally that time has gone by,
but I also can feel
like I can be back there
in a moment's notice like that.
Even if it does feel almost
watching a home movie.
And then when you were
watching the home movie of you,
what did you think and feel and remember?
- It was a really bizarre,
psychological experience for me, honestly,
because I had the video in my house.
I gave it to my husband and I just said,
put it into sort of
like the darkest corner
that you can find, just know where it is.
And that moment of just
in case happened when
I was talking to Amy and she asked if
she could see slash use
the video and the series.
And my first reaction was like,
absolutely not like, no,
I draw the line here.
This is too much, it is too personal.
I don't wanna see the video.
I don't want anybody
else to see this video.
And Amy, I don't know how
she talked me into it.
She managed to get the video taken.
I had my husband bring it
out of that dark corner,
wherever he stashed it in the closet.
And we watched it sitting in my house
and I just suddenly burst into tears.
And it hit me everything
from the tape, just,
I mean, it punched me right in the face
and I was just sobbing uncontrollably
for like a couple of days on and off,
about what I saw and just sort of
trying to mentally
reconcile the fact that
that little girl on the tape was me.
And she was talking about
something that happened to me
and it was overwhelming.
It's very difficult sometimes
to know that, that part of me,
is such a dark,
painful place, I mean.
'Cause when I look at my life now,
I have a wonderful husband,
I have a wonderful daughter,
I have a wonderful life and
I'm really excited about,
you know, my career writing and, you know,
taking my daughter to
kindergarten next year
and all the wonderful
things that surround me.
And yet there is this
impenetrable darkness,
deep, deep inside that,
I mean, I'm gonna be honest.
I still don't know what to do with.
- Wow.
How do you deal with any fears
that crop up as a parent?
'Cause I have mine from my
own history or my own stories
or things that are big triggers to me.
- I mean, I think about that a lot because
I do have things that
trigger me in my daily life.
Things that, you know,
are probably just like
completely stupid for other people,
that just send me
completely down the spiral.
And I'm actually kind of proud of myself
that I've gotten to the point where I can
see a trigger or experience
some sort of trigger, I freeze
and all that fun stuff happens.
The emotions, the recall, the sensations
and I can process it.
And sometimes it means waiting through
some of the negativity.
- How do you tell people
to handle their triggers,
if you see an image?
- I mean, this happened to
me, like, was it last week
maybe the week before,
I was just, you know,
scrolling through my newsfeed
and an article pops up that,
you know, who and his
wife went to a restaurant.
And I was just tailspin completely.
I was just like, I can't handle this.
I don't wanna see this.
Like, why are they gonna
restaurants anyway?
Like I was really very heavily triggered
and I was not okay.
And it took a couple of days
of me just sort of like
trying to like massage myself
back into a normal space.
- Can I ask, you know,
if people looking in who
maybe have not experienced
anything like this, is it the layers,
the repetition, the many years,
you watch the documentary and...
- I mean, the unfairness
of it, it's frustrating.
And then it makes me feel hopeless.
Like, what was the point of it all?
And then it's reminding
myself of facts that I know,
things that I can tether to.
The documentary did
accomplish something, I mean,
I think RAINN reported that
people were calling them
at an increased rate of about
20% during the documentary,
which means that survivors are out there
connecting with my story
and healing from it.
It's bittersweet thinking, you know,
like this story is something that connects
a lot of survivors who are hurting,
and okay, what more can we do for them?
Like how can we make
this world a space that
women feel empowered
or feel at least less terrified?
- That is so well said, thank you.
It really is, what a
perfect, amazing answer
to that question.
- It's tough because like,
I wish that I could say like,
here is like a 10 step plan to, you know,
completely feeling healed
and fulfilled in your life.
If you follow these steps,
you're gonna be just fine.
I wish I had that.
What works for me might
not work for somebody else.
So I think the best advice that I offer
is just be true to yourself
and the truth that you have lived.
- I think that's really good advice.
I really do.
(audience applauding)
I couldn't be more impressed by how Dylan
has handled herself, her history,
and even the criticism
aimed at her for decades.
Her resilience is a complete inspiration.
I'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back, it's time for Drew's News.
A very special, very
precocious Drew's news.
Because in season one,
we introduced you to our
adorable seven-year-old
kid reporter, Emmy Eaton, take a look.
We'd love to look forward to
the next generation of newsers.
And in that spirit, we
have a very special guest.
She is a budding young
journalist from Idaho Falls.
Who's becoming an internet
sensation for her interviews.
She's interviewed her mom,
her dad, her neighbors,
Keith Morrison, Lester
Holt, Doctor Oz, oh, my God.
She is a rising star,
and today, guess what?
Rossi we get to join
that illustrious list.
- I'm so honored.
- Please welcome seven year old,
behind the seventh questions
with Emmy, Emmy Eton.
- Emmy.
(audience cheering)
- Hey.
- I'm so excited to be
talking with you guys today.
- Oh, my goodness Emmy,
you've done over 40 interviews
and you've got such a natural talent.
What is it about interviewing
that you like so much?
- I like that I get to
talk to so many people
that are so amazing and
I love asking questions.
- Do you do research?
Do you pick your subjects?
What's your process?
- Well, I think of what they do.
Like if I were interviewing an author,
I would think, oh, what
book do they write?
And I would ask about that.
And if they like write
a fantasy, I would say,
okay, why did you wanna write a fantasy?
- I love it.
Have you always been curious
your whole entire life?
- Yes, I've been very curious.
- That's why you're a
good journalist, Emmy.
- Is there a story that you
would like for everyone to hear
today that you feel is important?
- There was this person,
she lives in Rexburg.
She made an igloo, they
call it the Skittle igloo.
They put pans of ice,
and then they all sued coloring
and they stuck it on the igloo.
There, the average they put lights in
so it looks really cool at night.
And the dad's a doctor,
so every day after delivering a baby,
he would get back to here on the igloo.
- Okay, Emmy, I just
wish you the very best,
and I want you to go out
there and keep asking
the important questions,
showing the fun things
that are happening in life.
And most importantly, would
you come back and visit us?
- Yeah.
- Okay, good, I'm so
glad, we need more Emmy.
The world needs more Emmy.
Thank you so much for coming today.
- Keep up the great work, Emmy.
- Thank you too.
- Just cute, she's so cute and wonderful.
Do go anywhere we've got more
seasoned two secrets coming up.
That's right.
(upbeat music)
♪ If you're into fashion ♪
♪ Or easy home decor ♪
♪ New favorite recipes ♪
♪ Plus fun celebrities ♪
♪ With a little good news ♪
We're back to bring you more.
♪ Barrymore, choose a
little for season two ♪
♪ Yeah, Barrymore, life
improving, stain removing ♪
♪ Barrymore ♪
- [Announcer] The new season of Drew,
premiere September 13th.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome back, that is
the end of today's trip
down memory lane, but fret not,
in less than a week, it's
the season two premiere
of the Drew Barrymore show.
And it is going to be huge.
We've got mega celebrity
guests, over the top segments.
I mean, no one would
think I would do that.
The Drewsiest, newsiest stories,
and you've got a chance
to win some serious cash
in a game we call Six Feet from 6,000.
But that's not all buckle up
for something we're calling Bestie Hour.
And that means my bestie is coming back.
Yes, it's an hour of me and Cameron Diaz.
And we have a whole bunch of surprises
for a bunch of besties out there.
You don't wanna miss it 'cause then
what would you talk
about with your bestie?
I mean, come on, tune in
September 13th, and until then.
(upbeat music)